الحادي عشر من نوفمبر المقبل يوافق يوم
العزاب او دبل اليفن هو اكبر يوم للتسوق
عبر الانترنت في العالم مبيعته اعلى من
ايام التسوق امازون برايم وبلاك فرايدي
مجتمعه شركات علي بابا الصينيه هي
المسؤوله عن الحصه الاكبر من مبيعات
التجاره الالكترونيه في اليوم منذ اطلاقها
المهرجان في عام 2009 في العام الماضي
حققت علي بابا مع المنصه المنافسه مبيعات
تقدر ب29
مليار دولار في يوم العزه ورغم ان نسخه
العام تشهد ظروفا اصعب مع اهتزاز ثقه
المستهلك الصيني بسبب قيود قرون المشدده
وتحضيرات التدخل الى ان التوقعات تشير وان
الاستهلاك لن يتاثر كثيرا يوم العذاب
بيمتدوا لاسابيه قبل يوم الحدث نفسه
لاختيار او الاختبار اتجاهات العملاء
ومعرفه ما يجذبهم قبل الحادي عشر من
نوفمبر وحاليا يكتشفوا طريقه تدريجيا خارج
حدوث الصين الى ناطق كثيره حول العالم في
اوروبا وحتى في امريكا اليك لميس لي
تعطينا مزيد من التفاصيل
عام
1992 بدا يوم العزاب كم مبادره مجموعه من
الطلاب من جامعه الاحتفال بفكره العزوبيه
وخلق منافس لعيد الحب انتشرت هذه الفكره
في جامعه مختلفه لذلك كان يطلق عليها يوم
البكالوريوس وتطورت بمرور الوقت كمناسبه
يمكن للرجال والنساء الذين ليس لديهم شريك
الاحتفال بها ومكافئه انفسهم بالهدايا لكن
لماذا يوم الحادي عشر من نوفمبر على وجه
التحديد يقال انا مبتكر الفكره كانوا
اربعه اصدقاء كل واحد منهم يمثل رقم واحد
في هذا التاريخ المكون من اربع وحدات يعني
اربعه عذاب يقفون بجانب بعضهم البعض لكن
بعد ذلك ب 16 عاما قررت مجموعه علي بابا
العملاق التضخيم من المبادره وخلق صله
بينها وبين التسوق عبر الانترنت من خلال
تقديم اسعار وعروض النرويجيه خاصه للعزاب
حاليا ينتشر يوم العزاب في جنوب شرق اسيا
كما هو متداول في مناطق مختلفه من اوروبا
واليوم اصبح فرصه للقاء العزاب وهو تاريخ
شائع ايضا لحفلات الزفاف
[موسيقى]
200 الف علامه تجاريه تشارك في كرنفال
تسوق الحالي بالصين يوم العزاب ومئتين من
تلك الشركات هي لي علامات فاخره واليكم
مزيدا من الارقام
50083 الف من الطلبات التي اعلنت عنها
منصه علي بابا هي للتعامل معها في الثانيه
الواحده في ذروه يوم العزاب لعام 2020 نحو
828 مليون متسوق عبر الهاتف شاركوا في يوم
العذاب خلال العام الماضي 60% هو حجم حصه
هذه المنصه علي بابا من مبيعات التجاره
الالكترونيه وفي المركز الثاني تاتي منصه
جيني دوت كوم ب 20 بالمئه من اجماليات 20%
من العلامات التجاريه في الصين تنوي
استخدامه المؤثرين الافتراضيين خلال العام
المقبل لتحسين تجربه التسوق
32% هي نسبه النمو في تنزيلات تطبيقات
تسوق خلال فتره يوم العزاب في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا واخيرا 70% من
المتسوقين في السعوديه والامارات حريصوا
على شراء المنتجات خلال يوم العزاب في عام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فقره الجنوب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا في
الاستديو الاعلاميه والصحفيه اقتصاديه سمر
اهلا بك صباح الخير لماذا يوم العزاء
تحديدا يحقق كل هذه المبيعات المهوله
المتحدث عن سيكولوجيه
مبدئيا خلينا يعني دائما اعشق هذا الموضوع
اللي وراء تسويق مثل هذه
الظواهر اليوم في يوم العزابي يتم خلق
ظاهره شو يعني ظاهره لما يكون في عندك
ظاهره لنفترض مثلا مسلسل
الكل يتكلم وانا مش عارفه شو هذا المسلسل
ضروري الان الان لازم همم انتمي الى هذا
الحدث او هذه الظاهره فحتى الشخص اللي ما
يريد يتسواق او ما عنده فضول لتسويق هو
يريد ينتمي الى هذه الظاهره فما بالك اذا
كانت الظاهره هي اهداء النفس هو ليش اسمه
يوم العزابيه كلها
عن اهداء النفس وحب النفس لانه اصلا اجت
يعني مثل مقابل الفالنتاين هناك
الفالنتاين عيد الحب اليوم عيدنا عيد
الاعزاء بالاشخاص
اليوم هذه الظاهره يعني خلق الظاهره
اورجنت الان لازم تحدث لازم اتسوق الان
وهذا اهداء لنفسي فهذا ادى الى
الباقيلارتي مثل ما شفنا 139 مليار دولار
هذا اقتصاد للمغرب تقريبا دوله مثل المغرب
كلها تمت خلال 24
طيب سمر اذا كان يوم العزاب بعتمد بشكل
اساسي على تخفيضات هذا العام مميز كله عام
اقتصادي بامتياز هل اخذوا الاعتبار مسائل
التضخم ومسائل انه المستهلك نفسه تراجعت
ميزانيته صحيح همم نادين اليوم الا مثل ما
ذكرت في تضخم في تراجع ميزانيه فاليوم
طبعا مره اخرى نعود الى اساليب التسويق
ركزوا على اللوينتي والفاليو اخلاص
المستهلك والفاليو اللي يقدمه لي اكثر لا
يركزوا اليوم على الخصومات يركزوا على
تقديم قيمه لهذا المستهلك المنتجات اللي
تعطي قيمه هناك تركيز مثل ما قلنا عليها
المنتجات العنايه الشخصيه العنايه بالبشره
ال همم العطور كل سنه يمكن كان في تركيز
اكثر على الالكترونيات اليوم هناك تركيز
على الاشياء اللي تخليني اشعر بشعور افضل
بشعور انا مميز هناك تركيز على
اللويرتين اللي هي فتح همم الابواب
للاشخاص اللي دائما يتسوقون او الفي اي بي
سبسكرايب بيرس قبل فتره يعني اليوم فتحه
لوريال مثلا
قبل يومين من يوم قبلي هوايه تسعه 11
فتحوا لهم الباب 82 ماركه باعت ب13 مليون
دولار خلال 24 ساعه اليوم راح يكون فيه او
غدا راح يكون في الجمعه همم 29,000 ماركه
لحد تدخل 200 ماركه فاخره جديده علامات
فاخره جديده على فتخيلي حجم المبيعات اللي
هيصير يعني اكيد هيتجاوز ال- 150 مليار
دولار
شكرا جزيلا للعالميه والصحفيه الاقتصاديه